تعتقد أن عمك سيرشح نفسه مرة أخرى
آسف لأنك لا تريد حتى التفكير في
الأمر أه هل تعتقد أنه سيركض
مرة أخرى يمكنه
نعم يمكنه آه شكرًا غروفر كليفلاند
أم لا ،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء
، سأعلم أنه موجود  بطريقة قال
إنه سيفعل ذلك غريبًا لأن
هذا نوع من التنازل عن الخسارة الآن
ولكني أعتقد أنه تم طرح ذلك في البداية
كوسيلة لإرضائه وتهدئة
غروره ،
لكنه لن يضع نفسه في
وضع يمكن أن يخسر فيه مثل هذا
مرة أخرى
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ثانيًا ، قد يعني ذلك لمدة
أربع سنوات أنه
يلعب دورًا داعمًا بشكل أساسي
والذي سيكون من الصعب جدًا عليه
الحفاظ
عليه وأنت تعلم الأهم من ذلك أنه خلال أربع
سنوات سيكون في نفس العمر الذي أصبح عليه جو بايدن الآن
ولكن
دونالد هو نفسه  شخص غير صحي
لديه نظام غذائي فظيع لا يمارسه
وهو يعرف الاضطرابات النفسية
التي تستمر دون علاج لذلك لا أتخيل حتى
أنه سيكون قادرًا على الركض في غضون أربع سنوات
بالإضافة إلى حقيقة أنه قد يكون كذلك
ينظر في  ز في أه تهم جدية
وجهت إليه